MALE SPEAKER: Thanks to all
of you for coming to this talk
by Michael Cremo on forbidden
archaeology here at Google.
So when was the last time
somebody questioned evolution?
Do you know?
In your experience, any numbers?
I'm just trying to say how
often it happens, somebody
questioning such a major
theory as evolution.
Any guess?
I mean, before the talk.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: It happens
all the time in the US.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
That's good.
That's good that people
are aware of that debate.
Some people don't even
know that it's a theory
and know it's being
debated, and they just
take it for a fact
as much as gravity.
That's good to know that
you are aware of that.
So we have Michael Cremo here.
So he has a lot of
extensive introduction
about how we got
into this topic.
So I don't want to steal that
as part of my introduction.
And so I'll just go over
the introduction of him
as a person.
I've known him for
more than 10, 15 years.
And he's a very thoughtful,
methodical person
with extreme
intellectual honesty.
And he expects that of others.
So that's where his research
was born into this book.
So the scope of
this talk is just
questioning the current
theory and based
on the evidences available.
But he's not going to present an
alternate theory in this talk.
We have to wait
for a year for that
to happen if he have
a job until then.
So now, the scope of
this talk is questioning
the current theory based
on the available evidences
from researched literature.
And the next topic
he usually presents
is called human devolution,
presenting an alternate theory.
So there are books
for that outside.
So that's your only
resource right now.
So with that, let's
welcome Michael Cremo
to Google with a big hand.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL CREMO: Thank you
for the nice introduction.
And thank you,
ladies and gentlemen,
for coming to hear a little
something about the topic
forbidden archeology, evidence
for extreme human antiquity.
So just to keep
things honest, I'm
a researcher in human
origins for the International
Society for Krishna
Consciousness.
And my research is
inspired by my studies
in the ancient Sanskrit
writings in India,
especially the Puranas,
the historical writings.
Now, for many today,
those two things
would be complete
disqualifications for me
to say anything about
a scientific topic
in scientific circles.
However, quite
surprisingly to me even,
there are people within
the scientific world who
are interested in hearing
what I have to say.
And I've been invited to present
my ideas at some of the leading
scientific institutions
of the world,
such as the Royal
Institution in London,
the Russian Academy
of Science in Moscow
Department of Anthropology,
the Indian Institute of Science
in Bangalore, and many
others around the world.
So the question
I'm dealing with is
how old is the human species.
Today, the most common
answer to that question
comes from the modern followers
of Charles Darwin, who
propose that the
first humans like
us came into existence less
than 200,000 years ago.
Before that, they
would say there
were no humans like us
present on this planet,
simply more primitive,
ape-like human ancestors.
However, the Puranas,
the historical writings
of ancient India,
give a different idea,
namely that humans
have been present
for vast periods of time
on this planet going back
many millions of years.
Now of course, in
scientific circles,
I wouldn't expect anyone
to take a statement
from some ancient
writings as evidence.
So in the scientific circles
where I'm invited to speak,
I do something else.
I make a prediction, namely
if what the Puranas say
about human antiquity
is true, there
should be reports of
archaeological evidence
for humans existing much further
back in time than 200,000
years ago, perhaps going
back many millions of years.
So my method for
testing that prediction
is to examine all archaeological
reports from the time of Darwin
to the present.
And not just in English.
I have a reading
knowledge of most
of the major European languages.
So when I speak about
examining reports
from the scientific
literature, I
mean two kinds of scientific
literature, the primary
and the secondary
scientific literature.
By primary scientific
literature,
I mean original reports by
archaeologists, geologists,
paleontologists, and
other Earth scientists
reported in the professional,
peer reviewed, scientific
literature.
By secondary literature,
I mean things
that are based on the primary
literature, such as textbooks,
for example.
So I had two principal findings.
The first finding is
not so surprising.
There are no reports of evidence
for extreme human antiquity
in the current secondary
literature, textbooks,
survey studies, and
things of that sort.
My second finding was a
little more interesting.
There are many
reports of evidence
for extreme human antiquity
in the primary scientific
literature of past and present.
So I collected those
reports and this book,
"Forbidden Archeology,"
which was reviewed
in most of the
professional, academic,
and scientific
journals that deal
with the question
of human origins.
So this constitutes a
kind of peer review.
Now, as you might expect, many
of those reviews were negative,
some extremely so.
However, quite
surprisingly to me even,
even some of my critics
were able to point out
some positive
aspects of the work.
For example, David Oldroyd,
a noted historian of science,
in a 28 page review
article about the book
asked the question, so
has forbidden archeology
made any contribution
to the literature
on paleoanthropology.
Our answer is a guarded
yes for two reasons.
First, he said, much of
the historical material
has not been scrutinized
in such detail before.
In other words, as a
professional historian
of science dealing with
these particular questions,
he had not encountered
any work which
had gone into history
in such depth before.
And second, he said,
the book raises, quote,
a central problematic
regarding the lack
of certainty in
scientific truth claims.
Now, after the
book was published
and many of the
reviews came out,
I began speaking about
the topic of the book
at scientific conferences.
The first time I
did that was in 1984
at a meeting of the World
Archaeological Congress.
It's the world's largest
international organization
of archaeologists.
I presented a paper there
called "Puranic Time
and The Archaeological Record."
And that paper was
selected for publication
in a peer reviewed conference
proceedings volume called
"Time and Archaeology,"
which came out from Rutledge,
a major scientific publisher.
And subsequently, I've
presented papers on my work
at many other meetings of the
World Archaeological Congress,
and also meetings of
the European Association
of Archaeologists.
And the reason I'm
mentioning this
is just to show that the
kinds of things I'm saying
are part of the
scientific discourse
in the scientific
disciplines that
are related to human origins.
Now, admittedly, it's
not a popular voice.
It's an extreme minority
voice limited maybe even
to a minority of one.
But still, surprisingly
enough to many people,
it is a part of the discourse.
So one of the questions I had
about the kind of evidence I'm
talking about is
why exactly is it
missing from the current
secondary literature
if it's there in the
primary literature.
And I'm proposing it's because
of a process of knowledge
filtration that operates
in the world of science.
And here, I'm not talking
about a Satanic conspiracy
to suppress truth.
I'm talking about
something that philosophers
of science and
historians of science
have understood for
a long time, namely
that theoretical preconceptions
can influence how scientists
may react to different
categories of evidence that
come to their attention.
We can call the blue box
the knowledge filter.
And what it represents
is the dominant consensus
in the scientific discipline
at a particular point in time.
And reports of
evidence that conform
to the dominant consensus will
pass through the knowledge
filter fairly easily,
whereas reports
of evidence that
radically contradict
a dominant consensus
tend to be filtered out,
ignored, forgotten,
set aside, dismissed.
And this was something that one
of the reviewers of "Forbidden
Archeology" noted, the
French archaeologist Marylene
Patou-Mathis noted in her
review of "Forbidden Archeology"
in "L'Anthropologie."
"Cremo and Thompson have
written a provocative work
that raises the problem of the
influence of the dominant ideas
of a time period on
scientific research.
These ideas can
compel the researchers
to orient their
analyses according
to the conceptions
that are permitted
by the scientific community."
So it was interesting to
me that an archaeologist
grasped correctly
what the point we
were trying to make in the book
and wasn't just dismissing it
as, oh, these are
conspiracy theorists.
I'm now going to go over
some of the kinds of reports
that I'm talking about.
This is Virginia Steen-McIntyre,
an American geologist.
She was involved in dating
an archaeological site
at Hueyatlaco in Mexico.
There, archaeologists had
discovered projectile points
and other stone
tools and weapons.
And they were, of
course, interested
in how all these things were.
This is the excavation
at Hueyatlaco.
And the artifacts were
photographed intact
in the layers of rock in
which they were found.
Virginia Steen-McIntyre
and her colleagues
used four different
methods to date the site.
Animal bones with
butchering marks
were found in the same
layers with the stone tools.
The geologists used the
uranium series method
to date those bones.
They got an age
of 245,000 years.
Above the layer
with the stone tools
was a layer of volcanic ash.
The geologists used the Zircon
Fission Track method to date
that layer of ash.
They got an age
of 270,000 years.
Using all four methods
that they employed,
the geologists
concluded the site
must be at least
250,000 years old.
However, the archaeologists
refused to accept it.
They said humans capable of
making those artifacts didn't
exist anywhere in the
world 250,000 years ago.
They hadn't evolved
yet, what to speak
of being present
in North America.
They considered the oldest
human presence in North America
to go back only
about 20,000 years.
So they refused to publish
the age for the site
given by their own hand-picked
team of geologists.
So Virginia Steen-McIntyre
and her colleagues
were a little surprised by that.
So they decided to
independently publish
the age for the site
in a journal called
"Quaternary Research."
But when they did
that, they experienced
an extreme negative backlash
from their colleagues
in the scientific
world because they
had dared to publish
something like this.
Virginia Steen-McIntyre
wrote to one
of the editors of the journal,
"Not being an anthropologist,
I didn't realize how deeply
woven into our thought
the current theory of
human evolution has become.
Our work at Hueyatlaco has been
rejected by most archaeologists
because it contradicts
that theory."
So some of the cases I'm
going to be talking about
are from the more recent
history of archaeology,
some from the more distant
history of archaeology.
Some of the cases
are going to be
closer to what the
mainstream concepts allow.
And some are going to be further
and further distant from what
current ideas would
consider possible.
This is one of the founders
of modern archaeology, Jacques
Boucher de Perthes.
And one of his excavations,
Moulin Quignon near Abbeville
in Northeastern France, he found
an anatomically modern human
jawbone.
He found it in the bottom
layers of his excavation
with stone tools and weapons.
According to modern geologists,
that layer at Abbeville
is about 430,000 years old.
It was quite a
controversial discovery,
even in the 19th century.
Many scientists could
not accept that humans
existed at that
distant point in time.
So some of them proposed,
well, Boucher de Perthes
must have been the
victim of a hoax.
Somehow or other,
someone must have
gone to some Roman cemetery,
gotten a jawbone 2,000 or 3,000
years old and buried it in the
excavation for him to find.
And that's actually
the explanation
that we see in
today's textbooks.
However, what we do not
see in today's textbooks is
that after these hoax
accusations came out,
Boucher de Perthes made
additional excavations
at Moulin Quignon.
And these additional
excavations,
in the same location
he found over 100
additional anatomically
modern human bones and teeth
in the same formation,
which to me indicates
a human presence going
back over 400,000 years.
And I reported on this case
in this paper, which was later
published in a peer reviewed
conference proceedings volume.
Recently, just last
year, archaeologists
reported the discovery
of footprints
at a place called Happisburgh
in the United Kingdom.
They were found in
a formation that
is at least 780,000
years old and is perhaps
up to a million years old.
The archaeologist who studied
the footprints published
results suggesting
they are consistent
with anatomically
modern human footprints.
For example, they
studied the foot index,
which is the width divided
by the length times 100.
The average for all of the
Happisburgh footprints was 39.
The average for living Native
American Indians is again, 39.
The average for living Eskimos
today, the foot index is 38.26.
And other features
of the footprints
were consistent with those
of modern human beings.
Now, of course they
did not believe
that humans like us
existed at that time.
They don't think Homo sapiens
existed over 780,000 years ago.
So they attributed
the footprints
to a species called
Homo antecessor, an ape
man that they believe
inhabited Europe at that time.
But from the evidence itself,
they could just as well
have been made by
humans like us.
And there is evidence that
anatomically modern humans
existed at that time.
This is the Buenos
Aires Skull, which
was discovered early in the
20th century in Argentina.
Researchers were
conducting digging.
And they had gone
down about 45 feet.
And they encountered
a solid layer
of limestone rock
locally known as Tosca.
And after they broke
through that layer,
they found a human skull cap
of an anatomically modern
human type in the
[INAUDIBLE] formation,
which geologists consider to
be 1 and 1/2 million years old.
This discovery was reported
to the scientific world
in the primary
scientific literature
by the South American
scientist Florentino Ameghino.
I reported on this
case and some others
in this paper presented
at a meeting of the World
Archaeological Congress in
Cape Town, South Africa.
Many people have heard
of Olduvai Gorge.
Many important discoveries
have been made there.
Most people are not aware
of the first discovery that
was made at Olduvai Gorge
by the German scientist Hans
Reck, who reported
on it in 1913.
He found a fairly complete,
anatomically modern
human skeleton-- that's the
skull cap of it-- buried
in upper bed II
of Olduvai Gorge.
Upper bed II of Olduvai
Gorge is between 1.15 and 1.7
million years ago.
It was a very
controversial discovery.
There were decades
of debate about it.
Many people thought the
debates were finally
settled in the 1970s when
a German scientist named
Reiner Protsch did a radiocarbon
test on a fragment of bone
that he said was
from Reck's skeleton.
And he got an age of
less than 10,000 years.
However, I question
the reliability
of that given that Reiner
Protsch was removed
from his position at
Frankfurt University
after an academic
committee there found him
guilty of having forged
dozens of radiocarbon dates
during his long career there.
Another report from the
earlier history of archaeology,
the jaw, fossil
human jar reported
by Doctor Robert Coliyer.
This anatomically
modern human jaw
was found 16 feet deep in the
Red Crag Formation in England
at a place called Foxhall.
The Red Crag
Formation, according
to modern geological studies,
is between two and three
million years old.
In 1979, Mary Leakey announced
the discovery of footprints
at a place called Laetoli
in the country of Tanzania
in East Africa.
According to her
report, the footprints
were indistinguishable from
modern human footprints.
Other scientists also agreed.
Paleontologist Tim White wrote,
"Make no mistake about it.
They are like modern
human footprints."
Now, neither Mary
Leakey nor Tim White
believe those footprints
were made by humans like us.
They propose they were made
by some type of ape man
who lived at that time who just
happened to have feet exactly
like those of
modern human beings.
Actually, we have the
skeletons of the ape men
that existed at that
time in eastern Africa.
They're called Australopithecus.
And the foot bones
of Australopithecus
have been discovered.
And their foot is
not exactly like that
of a modern human being.
They have very long toes, sort
of like short human fingers.
In other words, their feet
were somewhat ape like.
Actually, the only creature
known to science today
from skeletal evidence that
has a foot exactly like that
of a modern human
being is, in fact,
modern human beings
like ourselves.
So what did Mary Leakey find?
I think we have to remain open
to the possibility she found
evidence that humans
like us were present
almost four million years ago.
The footprints were
found in layers
of solidified volcanic
ash that were dated
using the potassium argon method
as being 3,700,000 years old.
I presented evidence
on this case
at a meeting of the European
Association of Archaeologists
that was held in England.
Now, some people might
say, OK, footprints
are perhaps a little
bit ambiguous.
It would be better if there
were human skeletal evidence
almost four million years old.
Such things have
been reported in
the primary
scientific literature.
For example, the
Italian geologist
Ragazzoni reported
finding human skeletal
remains at a place called
Castenedolo in northern Italy.
They were found
in layers of rock
that modern geologists
consider to be
about four million years old.
I went to the village
of Castenedolo.
I met this gentleman there.
And he gave me a copy of a very
rare geological report dealing
with this discovery.
And from the information
in the report,
we were able to
locate the place where
the discoveries were made.
Now, the current explanation
of these discoveries
is, well, it's not
really possible
that you could have anatomically
modern human skeletons
in layers of rock four
million years old.
So the proposal is that
maybe about 4,000 years ago,
somebody died on the surface.
His friends dug a grave
and put the skeleton down
in that ancient layer of rock.
And that's why
you think you have
a human skeleton four
million years old.
Things like this can
happen, technically.
It's called intrusive burial.
However, if you look at
Ragazzoni's original reports
in the Italian
language, which I did,
he says-- because
even at the time,
he was a professional geologist.
He was aware of the possibility
of intrusive burial.
He said, if it had been
an intrusive burial,
the layers of rock
above the skeleton
would have been undisturbed.
However, he found
that the layers
of rock above the skeleton were
all intact and undisturbed.
Actually, he said each layer has
its own micro-stratigraphy that
was undisturbed.
So I take this as evidence
for human presence going back
over four million years.
This is Carlos Ribeiro, who
was the chief government
geologist of Portugal.
He found hundreds
of human artifacts
in his country of Portugal.
He found them in layers
of rock that date back
to the early Miocene
Period, which
means they would be about 20
million years old according
to today's understanding.
He, as a professional geologist,
he said they cannot have come
into those layers from any
higher level through any
fissure, or crack, or all
the usual kinds of counter
explanations.
He displayed the artifacts
in the Museum of Geology
in Lisbon.
But if you go there today,
you won't see them on display
anymore.
They're kept in the
cabinets behind me.
But I was able to get
permission from the directors
of the museum to
study and photograph
some of these human artifacts
from the early Miocene period.
I also carefully studied
Ribeiro's original maps,
and field notes,
and correspondence
of the museum archives.
And then I went into the
countryside of Portugal
and I relocated
some of the sites
where he made his discoveries.
This is the quarry
at Murganheira.
And he found human
artifacts there
in lower Miocene formations.
This is one of them.
It's a flint artifact.
It's interesting what happened.
When Ribeiro was
alive, the artifacts
were displayed in the museum
with labels showing a lower
Miocene age for them,
about 20 million years.
After he died, his
colleagues in the museum
did something interesting.
They left the
artifacts on display,
but they wrote new
labels for all of them.
This is the new label they
wrote for the artifact I just
showed you.
Second line gives the
age-- Paleolitico Superior,
Upper Paleolithic Period.
According to geologists
today, that period in Europe
goes back about 20,000 years.
So it's interesting.
Ribeiro's colleagues
thought 20 million years,
that's clearly impossible.
20,000 years, that
sounds about right
for discoveries like this.
So they just wrote new labels
for all of the artifacts.
Now, the next generation
of officials in the museum
just put the entire
collection away.
And I'm the first researcher
to see these things in over 50
years.
I presented a paper on
this case at a meeting
of the European Association
of Archaeologists
that was held in Lisbon,
Portugal in the year 2000.
That paper was later
published in a peer reviewed
scientific journal from
Europe, "The Journal of Iberian
Archaeology."
A case that's
always fascinated me
has been the California
gold mine discoveries.
Gold was discovered
in California.
And miners went to places
like Table Mountain
in Tuolumne County near Sonora.
Actually not too far from here.
And deep inside the
tunnels, the miners
found human bones
and human artifacts.
For example, they found
many of these stone mortars
and pestles.
What makes them so
interesting to me
is they were found in
layers of solid rock
that date to the early part
of the geological period
called Eocene, which
means they would
be about 50 million years old.
Some of the details about the
dating of the discoveries.
It was done in modern times
using the potassium argon
method and analyzing
the plant and animal
fossils found in
those layers of rock.
These discoveries
were originally
reported to the scientific
world by Doctor JD Whitney, who
was the chief government
geologist of California.
His report was published by
Harvard University in the year
1880.
But we don't hear very much
about these discoveries today
because of the process
of knowledge filtration
that I mentioned.
This is the anthropologist
William Holmes,
who worked with the
Smithsonian Institution.
And he wrote in his report, "If
Doctor Whitney had understood
the theory of
human evolution, he
would not have published
those discoveries."
In other words, he would've
known that humans could not
possibly have
existed at that time.
A few years ago,
I was a consultant
for a television documentary
called "The Mysterious
Origins of Man"
that aired on NBC.
And the producer
of this documentary
had read my book,
"Forbidden Archeology"
and wanted to include some
cases in the documentary.
I told him he should go to
the Museum of Anthropology
at the University of
California at Berkeley
because artifacts from
the California gold mines
were still in that collection.
And the museum officials
refused to allow
him to see the artifacts.
Anyways, we were able
to get some photographs
of the artifacts
that Doctor Whitney
had taken in the 19th century.
It was interesting what happened
when this documentary aired.
Actually, many
scientists were outraged
and they wanted the FCC to
investigate NBC, censor NBC,
fine NBC millions of dollars for
having aired this documentary.
And I'm happy to say the FCC
didn't do any of those things.
But it was interesting that
such attempts were made.
Later, I went back
to the museum myself.
And I personally was given
access to the discoveries,
and they are still there.
They also went out to
Table Mountain near Sonora.
And we were able to relocate
some of the old 19th century
gold mining tunnels where these
discoveries were originally
made.
I reported on this case at
this meeting of the World
Archaeological Congress that was
held in Washington, DC in 2003.
So how far back in time can
we go with evidence like this?
In 1862, a scientific
journal called
"The Geologist" published
an interesting report.
An anatomically
modern human skeleton
was found 90 feet
below the surface
of the ground in Macoupin
County in the state of Illinois
near St. Louis.
According to the report,
above the skeleton
was a thick layer of slate
rock that was unbroken.
That's an important detail,
because it kind of rules out
the intrusive burial hypothesis.
This report from
"Scientific American"
tells of a beautiful,
metallic-- whoops.
I wanted one more detail.
According to modern
geologists, the layer
where the skeleton was found
is about 300 million years old.
This report from
"Scientific American"
tells of a beautiful
metallic vase
that was found 15 feet deep in
solid rock in Dorchester, which
is in the Boston area.
According to modern
geological reports,
the age of a formation at
that location and depth
is about 600 million years
from the Cambrian Period.
Now, I could actually keep
you here for days, and days,
and days because
there are hundreds
of reports like this in the
primary scientific literature.
I'm not going to do that.
But I'll make some
concluding remarks.
The significance
of this evidence
would be that it
would contradict
the now dominant ideas
about human origins.
And this was actually
recognized by one
of the architects of the
current paradigm, Doctor William
Howells of Harvard, who
wrote to me after he
read "Forbidden Archeology."
And he said a few
things about it.
He said, "'Forbidden
Archaeology' represents much
careful effort in critically
assembling published
materials."
I thought it was nice
that he recognized that.
And then he said, "Most
of us, mistakenly or not,
see human evolution with
man emerging rather late."
And that's the actual fact.
Most scientists actually
do see things that way.
And he went on to say, "To have
modern human beings appearing
a great deal earlier would be
devastating to the whole theory
of evolution."
So that's what he saw as the
impact of this kind of evidence
if it were to be
taken as genuine.
Now, not everybody is willing
to do that, admittedly.
Now, another
interesting statement
about "Forbidden
Archaeology" was
made by archaeologist Tim
Murray in his review published
in "British Journal for
History of Science."
Now, Murray is
one of my critics.
And still, even though
he's not really prepared
to accept my conclusion, he
has some interesting things
to say that I think
are worth repeating.
He said, "'Forbidden
Archeology,'" quote,
"provides the historian of
archaeology with a useful
compendium of case studies
in the history and sociology
of scientific knowledge, which
can be used to foster debate
within archaeology about how
to describe the epistemology
of one's discipline."
And that's actually
what I was trying
to do in putting that book
together, to foster debate
within archaeology about the
epistemology of the discipline.
And to see this acknowledged
in the professional literature
was kind of interesting.
Now, he went on to say,
"'Forbidden Archaeology' is
designed to demolish the case
for biological and cultural
evolution and to advance the
cause of a Vedic alternative."
Now, I plead guilty
to that indictment.
And it's at this point that many
in the world of science today
are really going to
have strong objections
to the kinds of
things that I do.
This mention of Vedic
alternative, in other words
some alternative
that has its roots
in some religious
or spiritual idea.
According to many in
the world of science
today, this is
completely verboten.
That's why I called the
book "Forbidden Archeology."
But it's interesting what Tim
Murray had to say about that.
He said, "The 'dominant
paradigm' has changed
and is changing.
And practitioners
openly debate issues
which go right to the conceptual
core of the discipline.
Whether the Vedas have
a role to play in this
is up to the individual
scientist's concern."
And I think that's an
enlightened attitude
that I can support.
No ban, but it's just
up to each individual
to make up their
mind whether or not
they're going to try to do
something like I'm doing
or agree with it.
Gets you into a whole discussion
about religion and science.
Now, I'm going to close
with some of my experiences
in presenting this kind
of thing at university
audiences around the world.
I've spoken at hundreds of
universities around the world.
My books are now in about
25 different languages.
One of them is Russian.
So I've lectured at a lot
of universities in Russia,
from Vladivostok to
Saint Petersburg.
And usually, the
lectures go fine.
At this particular university,
the Tyumen State University,
there was a little
bit of a problem.
Some professors there
had invited me to speak.
And a lecture was scheduled.
But when other faculty
members found out
that I was being
invited to speak,
they approached
the administration
of the university and
said, we can't have this.
We shouldn't allow this person
to speak at our university.
First of all, he's
contradicting a dominant theory.
And second, and
even more damningly,
he's doing it from some Vedic
spiritual kind of perspective.
So the president of the
university cancelled
the lecture.
The professors who invited me
and wanted to hear me speak
went to the president and tried
to get him to change his mind.
But the pressure from the
other side was just too big,
so the lecture was cancelled.
So then, the professors
who invited me
went to the local branch of the
Russian Academy of Sciences.
And they spoke to
the director there.
And he said, OK,
if they won't let
him speak at the university,
he can speak here
at the Russian Academy
of Science building.
So they had buses bring
students and professors
from the university to the
Russian Academy of Science
building.
And the professors who invited
me said, more people came then
would've come if the lecture
had been held at the university.
And then the next year,
something interesting happened.
I went back to the
same university,
and I was able to speak
at the biology department
there no problem.
I guess they just thought,
better let him talk
and let people just make
up their minds about what
he's saying.
They're intelligent.
They'll be able to figure out
if they can agree or not agree.
It's not going to be the end
of the world if he talks.
These are some of my works--
"The Forbidden Archaeologist,"
"Forbidden Archaeology," "Hidden
History of the Human Race,"
"Human Devolution," "My
Science, My Religion."
Some contact information.
And if you do like the kinds
of things you've heard today
and are interested
in hearing more,
you may want to
come on this cruise
where I'm the speaker
in June, 2015.
Go up and see the glaciers
and hear some weird stuff.
So I have ended five minutes
before I intended to.
[APPLAUSE]
I did want to leave
some time for questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
We'll start from here.
AUDIENCE: So I was also hoping
to get your point of view
from Vedic or Purana on
the how old is humanity,
and what did you find there.
Because I think in
the talk, somebody
replied that you would also come
to know about religious books,
like Ramayana or
Mahabharata, how much of that
is true based on the
archaeologic [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL CREMO: Well, it depends
upon what kind of circles
I'm speaking in.
For example, if I go to
Rishikesh or Haridwar
in the Himalayan
mountains and sit around
with a bunch of Vedic
scholars who accept statements
from Vedic literature
as evidence, then,
well, I can say in
the Bhagavad Purana,
there are statements
that humans were existing
during the [INAUDIBLE]
Period, which
is in the first part of
the Culpa, or the day of--
and they'll understand
what I'm saying.
And they'll accept
that as evidence.
If I'm at a meeting of the
World Archaeological Congress,
or speaking at
Google headquarters,
my audience is not
necessarily going
to accept a statement
from the Bhagavad
Purana or the
Mahabharata as evidence.
So it's like if you
go to a baseball game,
you have to play by the
baseball game rules.
And one of the rules is that
you can't use a statement
from a spiritual
text as evidence.
Now, you can.
So for the people who do--
I get questions like yours
from many people.
They want to say,
OK, you've given
all this archaeological
evidence that you
say is consistent with
Vedic texts, which talk,
according to you,
in a general way
about extreme human antiquity.
But what do they actually
say, the Vedic literature
themselves?
So for such people,
I'm writing a book
in which I will collect
all those Vedic statements.
And then they can see.
But that's not the audience
that I am presented with today,
that I'm presenting to today.
It's not the audience that
I get at universities.
It's not the audience
that I get at meetings
of the World Archaeological
Congress or European
Association of Archaeologists.
A good question.
And I'm writing a
book to answer it.
AUDIENCE: Could you say more
about the actual contradiction
between the extreme antiquity
of humans and evolution?
Because in my mind,
it would just seem,
well, the evolution
theory could just
be oh, you just have to push
it back a few million years
and it could still hold up.
It's just that it happened a
lot earlier than people thought.
That seems like a
simplistic resolution.
But is there
something else that's
constraining the timeline which
makes it really inconsistent?
MICHAEL CREMO: Well,
it's a good question.
I'll refer you back to the
statement of William Howells,
who said, if the kind of
evidence that I'm talking about
is consistent, it's inconsistent
with the general theory
of evolution.
Because he said-- I
didn't quote everything
he wrote to me in his letter.
He said, but you're
putting evidence
for an anatomically
modern human presence
before the known presence
of even the most simple apes
and monkeys, which would be
our prospective ancestors.
So you could conceivably
come up with another version
of the evolutionary
theory, but it
would be quite
different from anything
that's being proposed today.
So that would be one
possible response,
to do something like that.
And if you feel inspired
to do it, then right on.
This
AUDIENCE: So you talked a lot
regarding your critics throwing
out the archaeological
evidence based on it just
being out of their paradigm,
filtering it away, and so on.
But some of the critics who've
truly engaged your work,
has it been just
that, or do they
have valid,
scientific reasons why
they're refuting your evidence?
MICHAEL CREMO: Normally--
I mean, everybody's
going to have to make up their
own minds about these things.
What I try to do in
"Forbidden Archeology"
was provide in each case all
of the different opinions,
all sides of the
question, and leave it up
to the reader to make up
their own mind whether they
think it's valid or not.
Typically, the
reactions are to suggest
first of all, it's old evidence.
In other words, but
this is very selective.
It's the idea that--
kind of like a milk
carton, scientific evidence
got an expiration date.
That any science
conducted before midnight,
January 1, 1900
somehow has expired.
But I noticed that those who
make that type of criticism
are applying it
very selectively,
because the standard
textbooks of archaeology
are full of
discoveries that were
made in the 19th century,
early 20th century.
So it can't just be that
just because something
is from the earlier
history of archaeology,
it has to be wrong.
Another category
of objection has
to do with lists of ways in
which something could be wrong.
It's possible there was a hoax.
It's possible it could've
slipped in through a fissure.
It's possible that the original
investigator made a mistake.
It's possible this,
it's possible that.
My general response to
that category of criticism
is everything is
certainly possible.
But if you're going to
proceed in a scientific way,
you should be able to show that
in this particular location,
there was a fissure.
There were artifacts
on the surface that
resemble those that were
found at that level.
And there definitely was a way
they could have got down there.
So that's another
category of objection.
And of course, I'm willing
to engage on that level.
And it's one of
the things I hope
to accomplish with the book is
to have a second look at some
of these things.
And if there are
objections, raise them.
AUDIENCE: My question
is you mentioned
about a guy that in 19th century
found a jawbone in a layer that
was 400,000 year old.
How did they knew
in 19th century
that this particular
layer was that old
without any dating methods?
MICHAEL CREMO: OK.
It's a good question.
What I said, if you
listened carefully,
was that according
to modern geologists,
the layer is a certain
number of years old.
At that time, they characterized
things in another way,
not using necessarily
years, but characterizing
things as early Pleistocene,
early middle Pleistocene,
and things of that sort.
So if you translate those
terms to the modern dates that
are attached to those
terms, it works out.
So they would have
said, that jawbone
was found in an early
Pleistocene layer, which
would mean it would have
to be several hundred
thousand years old at least.
That's why I went by the modern.
To give an age in years, I
went by the modern geological
dating of those
layers at Abbeville.
For example,
Ribeiro, he would've
said these stone tools
are early Miocene.
Now, in the 19th century,
the conception of the Miocene
was there.
But it wouldn't be exactly
the number of years
that we now attach to it.
But still, it was
considered to be very old
in terms of the succession
of geological layers.
But just for current reference,
I give the estimates in years
that modern geologists have
determined for these layers.
The same with Doctor
Whitney's report.
He would have said, these layers
are from the Pliocene Period,
which is an old
geological period.
Now, the layers that
he considered Pliocene
are considered to be Eocene.
And the age for them is between
30 and 50 million years.
In the 19th century,
they wouldn't
be using the same number
of years that we do.
But they had a concept
still that, in terms
of the system they were
using, it was older.
They expected human
beings like us
to appear only in the very
latest, very recent Pleistocene
Period.
So if it was from the middle
or the early Pleistocene,
that would be
anomalous for them.
Is that helping?
AUDIENCE: Let's say
it's 19th century.
We dig a hole in the ground
and we find few layers.
And they somehow decided,
oh, this layer is younger,
this is older
based on the depth.
But then they put
some dates to it.
And I think it's almost
the same as right now.
We also have layers and they
have dates attached to them.
And my concern is that maybe we
just attached the dates badly.
How do you know exactly?
Just like they might be
wrong about the dates
in 19th century, they might
be wrong about the dates
right now.
MICHAEL CREMO: I'm
prepared to accept
that if we want to say we
don't know how old anything is,
really, and all the dating
methods are unreliable,
we could certainly do that.
That's one approach to take.
The approach, however,
that I've taken
is you have to have
some kind of framework
for discussing things.
And I'm addressing an audience
of geologists, archaeologists,
paleontologists.
And my way of creating a frame
of reference for the discussion
is to say, according to
methods that you consider
reliable-- radiocarbon dating,
potassium argon dating, uranium
series dating, zircon
fission-track dating--
these layers belong to
this geological period,
which you consider to be
millions of years old.
Now, if you want to take the
approach that, well, nothing
is reliable and we
don't know anything
about the real age
of anything, that's
certainly an approach
that could be taken.
And some out in the world--
say if you're a young Earth
Christian creationist who
believes that the Earth is
no older than
10,000 years, you're
going to be very critical of all
the different dating methods.
And that may be the
way that such a person
would approach this.
The Vedic time scales
are more or less
consistent with the
modern scientific time
scales for the universe, and
the Earth, and things like that.
So perhaps I'm not
motivated sufficiently
to try to dismiss all the
different scientific dating
methods.
AUDIENCE: Are there
cases where the age
of the layer and the dating,
some kind of scientific dating,
of the actual bones, say, is
the same and is very ancient?
MICHAEL CREMO: Well, there are--
if we're talking about bone,
there are only a
very few methods
that can be used to
directly date bone.
There's the radiocarbon method.
But that works only
back to about 50,000
or 100,000 years at
most because it's
based on the decay
of carbon-14, which
has a half life of
about 5,000 years.
And after about 20
half lives, there's
nothing left to measure.
There's the uranium
series method,
which is based on
the decay of uranium
to different daughter isotopes.
And by measuring the
ratios of those isotopes
and making certain assumptions
about intake and outflow
of ions, you can
date bone going back
a few hundred thousand years.
But if we're talking
about the formations that
are millions of years old-- say
early Pleistocene formations,
Pliocene formations,
Miocene formations,
there's no method
that will allow
you to directly date the bone.
Now, let's look, for example,
at the Castenedolo discoveries
from Italy, where Professor
Ragazzoni found human bones
in layers of rock from
the early Pliocene
Period, or middle
Pliocene Period.
There were attempts about
40 years ago to date
those bones using the
radiocarbon method,
and a young age was obtained.
Now, the problem
with that is if you
have a bone that really is,
say four million years old,
and it gets contaminated
with the least
amount of modern
carbon-14-- which
can happen in numerous ways
through the groundwater,
through just even a
scientist touching
the bone it can contaminate
it with recent carbon.
Then even if the bone really
is, say, four million years old,
if it's gotten
contaminated with the least
amount of modern carbon, which
can take place through bacteria
infiltrating it, through
any number of methods,
it will show an age of
100,000 years or less.
So each case has to be
looked at very carefully.
So there are cases--
but as I said,
the methods that you can
use to directly date bone
are limited to bones of, say, a
few thousand years old or less.
For many the cases
that I'm talking about,
the appropriate
method is to date
the age of the formation
at which the bone is found
and show it's not intrusive.
AUDIENCE: But you could say,
OK, well this layer is more
than 300,000 or
400,000 years old,
and the bone is shown to
be greater than 300,000,
something greater than 300,000.
But are there any
cases like that, then?
MICHAEL CREMO: I can't
think of any right offhand
because usually the attempt
is to show the bone is,
in the kinds of cases
that I'm dealing with,
there are attempts to
show that bone is not
as old as it's purported to be.
Undoubtedly, there
are cases like that.
But I can't-- I'm not able to
give you one right off the top
of my head.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious whether,
from your perspective,
the scientific evidence is
sufficient to convince you
by itself.
And if it is sufficient
to convince you by itself,
then why refer to the
Vedic texts at all?
Is there something special
about the Vedic texts
that mystical texts from
other cultures lack?
MICHAEL CREMO: Yeah.
It's a very good question.
And I am open about what my
epistemological commitments
are.
And if we study the
Vedic epistemology,
it tells us there are different
ways of getting evidence.
There are different
categories of evidence.
They're called pramanas.
One is called the
pratyaksha pramana.
That means sense
evidence, things
we can touch, see, measure.
Then there's anumana, which
means logical inference.
If it's like this and this,
then it must be like that.
These methods for getting
knowledge about-- especially
about things that are beyond
the range of the senses,
like what was happening millions
or billions of years ago,
they become problematic.
And therefore, according
to the Vedic epistemology,
one can rely upon another
type of evidence-- testimony.
It's called the
sabda pramana, which
is based on the idea there
is some kind of higher
intelligence that is
aware of these things
and can communicate
information about them.
And that's considered to be
a higher kind of evidence.
However, as I said, that is not
the epistemological assumption
that's dominant today
in the world of science.
If you actually go back
in European science,
even to 300 or 400
years ago, you'll
find that many of
the scientists had
similar epistemological
commitments where they were--
I mean, even, say, somebody like
Michael Faraday, a physicist
who did a lot of the work
that unified electricity
and magnetism.
He worked along with
Maxwell to come up
with the electromagnetic
field equations.
The reason why he
started looking for unity
was because he was a member
of a Christian sect called
the Sandemanians, who had the
idea that all energies are
unified in God.
So based on his
spiritual conviction
that energies are
unified, he was
inspired to do the work
that led to his integration
of electricity and magnetism.
And he also tried to bring
gravity into the equation.
It's something that's still
troubling physicists today,
how to bring gravity
into the whole picture.
But I understand that's not
the dominant epistemological
position today.
So I put that aside.
But you're asking me why.
Say if-- so my
position is I'm going
to represent an idea
from the Vedic text
if there is any evidence that
can be used to justify it.
If there were no
evidence, then I
wouldn't have anything to say
about it in scientific circles.
On my own, I might still
have the conviction
that that's true.
But I might stop trying
to represent that idea.
Say if somebody could convince
me that there is absolutely
no archaeological evidence
for extreme human antiquity,
I would still believe in extreme
human antiquity for the reasons
that I stated.
But I might stop trying to
talk about it to audiences that
don't have similar
epistemological convictions.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
I think with that, we
will end the session.
And we'll thank Michael Cremo
for visiting Google once again
and giving us this
wonderful talk.